canada's defense minister tells global
news more armored vehicles could be sent
to ukraine in addition to the eight
announced this week as the government
figures out how to spend the half a
billion dollars committed to ukrainian
military aid in the budget so there will
be a strategy behind the spending of the
500 million dollars
which may well include additional
vehicles anita onon says she talks to
ukraine's defense minister about their
needs almost daily but she won't say
where canadian soldiers are training
ukrainians on the m777 howitzers or just
how many canada sent
firstly because of security concerns but
secondly we are still engaged with our
allies and there is a potential to
continue to collaborate on the provision
of additional
weaponry onan spent time with secretary
lloyd austin this week not just at the
pentagon but at a meeting of nato allies
in germany austin had strong words about
russia we want to see russia
weakened to the degree that it can't do
the kinds of things that
it has done in invading ukraine neither
canada's prime minister nor defense
minister has matched that language this
week we also heard russia accuse nato
allies of being engaged in a proxy war
i'm wondering what you think about that
and and if you're worried that that
comments such as the one about weakening
russia could further antagonize putin
again i'm not overly concerned with the
rhetoric coming out of the kremlin i am
concerned with ensuring that we do
whatever we can
to militarily equip ukraine to fight and
win this war so busy with that i do not
have plans to visit ukraine of course in
their first meeting at the pentagon
anand and lloyd discussed more than
ukraine norad modernization has long
been promised by canada on and would
only say a plan is coming this spring
abigail beeman global news washington